evening I'm Stuart brand from the long
now foundation I've just been talking
with our speaker tonight one of the
peculiarities of archaeology he reminded
me of is that we assume the past is the
past
and after we've done a century or two of
archeology we assume that our knowledge
of the past is our knowledge of the past
and that's that then work that way we've
barely touched the past we have done
tiny amounts of digging and tiny amounts
of places and then formed these huge
speculations about what actually
happened what our story is actually made
of and because the instruments keep
getting better the theories are getting
better we'll hear some good ones tonight
there are more and more archaeologists
out there digging we keep finding we
keep retelling the story of how we got
here and this is not going to stop what
we're the history of humanity
interestingly enough is not only is our
future a work in progress
our past is a work in progress please
welcome sander Fanta later
[Applause]
well it's a great pleasure to be here I
can't see any of you because the light
is too strong but that's maybe a good
idea you'll have to find your own
reactions to this what I like about the
way Stuart just introduced me is that
indeed one of the things I'm going to
try and do is give a different very
personal reassessment of a couple of
million years of human history up to a
fairly recent present I'm clearly going
to do that in very large steps and there
are some underlying ideas that I'll try
and bring to the fore which I think have
direct relevance for what is happening
at present this is where I'm going to
start and I'm going to start here for
two reasons this is a series of three
little slides that posits a problem that
you all know very well and that has to
do with sustainability and I'm putting
that in there because I think my own
perspective as an archeologist has given
me a very different sense of what
sustainability is all about then what a
lot of people have I have come to that
topic because as an archaeologist I was
asked in the early 90s by the European
Union
to do a project on modern land-use
problems and the relationship in
particular between towns and rural
communities and I did that for 10 years
with a wonderful team of about 60
scientists from all over Europe which
was basically having my own private
University and organizing my own courses
the way I would like them and to see
what I could learn so what I'm
presenting here is a mixture of ideas
that come out of archaeology and ideas
that come out of the study of the
present and what I'm going to try and do
is bring all of this together it's very
much a work in progress and so there may
be moments where I do a hiccup or
something like that but we'll see how
far I can get these images speak more or
less for themselves on the left-hand top
side
you see an evolution of u.s. GDP below
its world Wells Indy sales per continent
and then on the top right cents and a
top and the bottom right as well of
where wealth is actually going in the
present time and I'm simply putting that
as one of the main issues that we have
to deal with the result of that is this
this is a graph that many of you will
have seen it comes from will Stefan's
work and it is basically a call to arms
for the sustainability movement and it
takes a very wide range because this is
only two of the graphs that he has and
basically shows the acceleration of the
sustainability problems that are hitting
us in every which direction
whether it's the damming of rivers
climates
pollution of the earth of the ocean and
so on and so forth and very recently
I've had the good fortune to participate
in a paper that takes the whole
sustainability issue out of climate
change alone and basically argues that
there are a number of other dimensions
where the earth is just as much under
threat of destabilizing itself due to
our influence and some of those I
mentioned on the right hand side so that
to me is the backdrop and I will only
come back to that at the end of my talk
when I'm talking about maybe ways in
which we could do something about this
but let's look at archeology for a
moment and look at what is your favorite
topic the long term there's a number of
reasons from my perspective to actually
look at very long term dynamics and this
comes out of the work I did in southern
Europe if you don't as most of us don't
you miss a whole package of dynamics
that are ultimately of great importance
moreover what you don't do is to observe
complete cycles of change if you have
the models
that now drive our economies whether
it's the World Bank or the government or
somebody else we basically look back for
about a hundred years maybe 200 years to
numerical data and we observe a very
narrow part of the total system
behaviors that could have happened and
more than that we actually observe a
highly biased part that is biased
towards all the things that have been
going on recently but to me more
important than anything else
as an archeologist is that we forget to
observe the change of change we don't
observe how processes themselves change
and in my own work over the last 20
years that has in many ways become the
most important lesson of long-term
sinking archaeology does this and as
Stewart just said it does it very in a
very fragmented way it has a lot of
trouble doing it but it has also a
couple of major advantages most of the
climate data is data that doesn't take
any humans or animals or plants very
much into consideration because it is
polar data and it goes through the gas
phase of the atmosphere there are very
rare sites and one of those we are
currently and when I say we it is people
in my department are currently digging
on the south coast of South Africa where
we have 300,000 years in one cave and so
loosely packed that we can actually
begin to distinguish different very
short periods Stewart was referring to
new techniques one of the more amazing
techniques that is now possible is we
can actually approximately date single
sand grains and that is helping us with
these kinds of things so what can
archaeology contribute it can contribute
an evolution of the terrestrial
environment over the very long term time
that takes humans into account but also
animals plants and everything else it
can also help us
with understanding the evolution of
human behavior and that is what a lot of
this talk is going to be about and then
finally it allows us to downscale from
global to regional and that is one of
the biggest problems that the
sustainability science right now has
coming as it does out of climate science
which is essentially global and we have
a lot of work to do to convince people
and IPCC is doing that for example to
convince people to actually start
looking at the regional scale because in
the end the adaptations have to be done
at the regional scale they can't be done
at the global scale
now the archaeological record is the
only one in my mind that can do these
things partly because it is not a
written history so it is not the bias of
individuals it is only present all over
the world and it integrates a very wide
range of sources on the other hand as
Stuart said it is very difficult to
interpret and our ad added problem is
and he didn't say that he left it to me
to say and I will do it with quite a
strong feeling about it we destroy all
the evidence that we don't already know
when we go out into the field we
recognize things those things that we
recognize we preserve or we record those
things that we don't recognize we don't
know about and we destroy them and so we
have a very slow proof cycle in
archaeology and because of that a lot of
archaeological evidence and my talk will
suffer from that in a major way is
actually based on getting the most
coherent picture together rather than
necessarily saying well this is the
truth that also for me personally is a
great privilege because it allows me to
roam much freer in my thinking about
these things then some of my colleagues
can do but that is another story
now these hockey stick curves as the
ones that will Stephan published the
ones that show this very rapid
acceleration they pose us as
archaeologists a
couple of questions on the one hand this
covers the last couple of centuries now
why did it take as millions of years as
a species to come to this particular
point and once we got there why did it
then go so fast and then finally and
I've left that for the last what is it
we don't know what I'm going to try and
defend here today is that it is not the
climate or the environment but that it
all hinges on the innovative capacity of
society and so I'm going to try and take
you through the evolution of human
cognition and innovation and outline a
number of the crucial transformations
that have happened over long-term time
in the way humans interact with their
environment so the question there is
what is different about humans that they
can develop such complex technologies as
we're currently doing and the first
question that you then get when you
think about humans who are both
biological beings and social beings is
what are the enabling factors are they
biological or are they essentially
socio-cultural now we're I'm going back
to is a particular concept that is the
short-term working memory that is the
sense that in our minds we can bring
together when we are thinking or doing a
limited set of informations that we can
manipulate transform do all kinds of
things too but it is very very limited
the difficulty of course for
archaeologists is that this is very very
difficult to document because what do we
have we have skulls we have skulls sizes
but we don't really have any ancient
evidence on the evolution of that
short-term working memory so I'm going
to have to approach that in two
different ways I'm on the one hand going
to compare
in the way of direct evidence the size
of the short-term working memory of
primates and that of human beings and
I'm also going to follow on the next
couple of slides a two lines of indirect
arguments that help us corroborate this
particular part of the story which is
the first part and the biological part
of the story what we know from any
experiments whether it's fronts the wall
or others observing them in in captivity
or
in the wild we know that chimpanzees can
crack nuts and that that involves
essentially three objects an anvil and
not an a hammer but we also know that
there is only about 75% of the
chimpanzees that can actually learn to
do this and the conclusion of the people
who are doing this research in much more
detail than I will ever be able to do is
that that short term working memory that
they have is essentially two plus or
minus one that is the best can indeed
deal with three objects can manipulate
those in ways they want but some of them
can't and always have only two objects
there are a number of other tests and I
don't want to go into those now that
point in the same direction ways in
which you can combine common combined
tokens the ways in which you can get
them to manipulate objects to combine
gestures and so on and so forth another
line of research argues that the
short-term working memory of modern
humans is actually a factor seven plus
or minus two now let's look at the
indirect evidence this is also by the
way I should say the human evidence is
also based on experiments on the number
of things that you can actually juggle
at the same time let's look at the
indirect evidence what we know is that
chimpanzees achieve that maximum
short-term working memory at an age of
two or three years old between 36 and 48
months
we also know that humans when they're
four or five can actually deal with
three objects everybody what is this
graph shows is a projection over the
first the first 14 years of human
existence of what that grows if we
assume that it is linear will actually
let us see that we then have at the age
of about 14 that working memory of 7
plus or minus 2 so this is not a
corroboration but it helps to understand
a little bit what is going on we have to
make two assumptions on the one hand
that the development is linear through
the age the beginnings of an animal or a
human's life and secondly that it
actually stops with adolescence the age
of two or three is adolescence for a
chimpanzee for humans it is let's say 13
or 14 so another way in which we can
begin to look at that is to calculate
the size of the brain relative to the
size of the body and that is what is
called the encephalization quotient that
is what is the relative growth of the
body of the other head respective to the
actual body and that is what is being
put on this particular graph on the
right hand side we look at essentially
six and a half million years ago and we
assume that chimpanzees at that time had
essentially the same working memory and
the same brain size as they do now and
we have some skeletons to actually
affirm that when you move towards the
left you actually move with time and you
see these bars that are essentially
illustrating where in time we actually
for the first time have evidence of more
than a factor two
of manipulable 'ti in the various proto
humans and humans that we have the
evolution of the triangles and the blue
dots and the two red rectangles are
different people's evidence about when
these particular subspecies actually are
found and that is what we're now getting
onto with the next slide because what
I'm going to do next
Oh No one slide in between so we have
this evolution of what is essentially
cognitive capacity we see over that
whole period a huge variability in
climate but we don't see any major
changes in what people can do and I'll
show you that in a moment so the
question then is why is that so why if
climate change was so dramatic cultural
change was actually minimal over that
whole long period and my argument there
is that the size of the short-term
working memory actually for that period
constrains the cognitive complexity of
early artifacts and what I'm going to do
in the next few slides is show you how
we can begin to trace how protohumans
and early humans have actually bent
their mind around the concepts necessary
to begin to make three-dimensional tools
and that is a long story that is a story
that took several million years the
simplest conception of an artifact is
essentially a combination of geometric
and topological properties and what I
will show you in a moment is an older
one chopper and what you can see there
is that there is a line of little chips
that were taken off a piece of stone and
that that is actually the earliest
evidence that we have of something that
is aligned so the cognitive complexity
of stone tool conception seems to me to
be an indicator for short-term working
memory development and you can make
similar arguments for all kinds of other
parts of human development
let me now very briefly first give you
an overview of the various kinds of
activities that we can see in the stone
and you should look at the column
concept which is the second column from
the left where we begin let's say in
stage three to look at the fact that
people were able or whatever they were
called in those days we're able to take
one little flake of a piece of stone
that demanded indeed three different
things because it demanded the stone
with which you hit the stone that you
hold and the cognition of the angle with
which you can actually hold hit that
stone so that the flake comes off that
incident angle has to be less than 90
degrees on the right hand side you
actually see in the red column that that
is the stage three of that short-term
working memory evolution and we have the
tools in this particular case in a site
called local ally in East Africa where
we find the evidence for this what we
begin to see them and much later is that
people do this repeatedly and initially
that repetition is simply repeating the
same act but in a second stage that
repetition becomes a goal-oriented
coordinated activity in which there is
actually a strategy involved those are
the two stages that I have here called
flaking and making an edge what then
happens is that you'd get an edge and
when you make the edge complete you
actually have encircled a surface and
what we see then is that initially in
the stone tool manufacture what happens
is that you get the edge first and then
people take off the surface and then
later they take off the surface
first and then started working on the
edge now that reversibility proves that
conceptually they actually distinguish
between the two dimensions the single
dimension line and the two-dimensional
surface in the next stage we actually
see this again in three dimensions and
I'm jumping a few stages here to get
down at the bottom which is stage number
seven where we actually start working
completely in three dimensions let me
now illustrate this with a few examples
of stone tools right here on top you
basically see dimension zero the point
then dimension 1 the line you basically
have an edge the second dimension is the
surface and I just talked about that and
the third dimension finally we get to
the volume in order to get there
much much much much later we actually
get a procedure that distinguishes
between a surface there a surface there
and a surface here that is the only way
you can explain that these particular
tools were being made now that is an
interesting sort of thing because it
allows us to follow through time what
the evolution of the capacity of humans
to begin conceiving in three dimensions
how that evolves of course all that time
they dealt with objects that had three
dimensions but they were not cognized
dimensions and what I'm talking here
about is the evolution of cognition here
you have some of the earliest examples
on the left hand side a cleaver from all
the way which is one and a half million
years old where you basically have a
couple of flakes removed on the side and
that creates the cleaver on the right
hand side you see the next stage which
is already a lot better where the edges
have been worked all around or to a
large part around and where the object
therefore gets a lot more shape a
particular critical stage is what
technically we call the Laval what
technique and that points to something
else it points to the fact that if you
want to start
making objects in series you want to
find ways so that taking off one object
one flake prepares for the next and so
people are beginning to learn that and
they do that by actually conceiving of a
stone as two halves or two parts and
working on those two parts alternately
so that they can actually get into that
kind of consider continuous activity
this is the result and what you see here
is of course that through time we gained
a huge amount of control over the
objects that we actually make you could
have only to compare the old urban
chopper and the solutrean blade to see
how much of that control we are getting
but you have to remember that that takes
actually about a million and a half
years to get there and it is my
contention that that process by the time
we come to the solutrean blade let's say
has achieved the capability of seven
factors in our short-term working memory
and that from that moment on we actually
don't haven't from then till now which
is only a relatively limited amount of
time of let's say a hundred and fifty
thousand maybe two hundred thousand
years we haven't really evolved that
biological capacity anymore
but then we haven't had to because by
the time you have the possibility to
deal with seven factors the combinatoric
czar such that you can actually deal
with a huge number of different things
so biology is no longer a constraint
what then becomes the constraint is to
do to extricate experimentally and by
thinking and by working different
conceptual tools with which we can
actually begin to build more and more
cone complicated objects so what we see
at that moment and that is from about
50,000 BC onward we see an explosion of
new operations so there is no longer a
constraint we can do for that moment at
least a very wide
of things now what happens at that
moment my basic theory is that from that
time onward we see a feedback loop in
information processing and I am very
deliberately therefore arguing that not
only our society is an information
society but that every society in the
past and in the present is essentially
an information society and that what
determines the growth through time of
the demographics the technology and
everything else is that feedback loop
between being more innovative coming up
with more concepts being able to do more
things because of that encountering also
more and more challenges having after a
certain moment no longer the capability
to deal with those with a very small
group of people so assimilating a larger
and larger group of people and that is
the sort of process that from that time
let's say 50,000 BC onwards I am
actually talking about and that then
leads to major social transformations
and let's very briefly summarize what is
available and I have not pointed to all
of them conceptually around 50,000 years
BC BP on the one hand we can distinguish
between reality and conceptions between
the objects and our ideas about the
objects we can categorize based on
similarities and differences we feed
back we feed forward we anticipate and
that to my mind is a very much
underplayed element in this whole story
and we can actually reverse between
looking backward and looking forward so
we can develop memory and control loops
we can generally we can generate
mentally events that could be different
because we are basically able to deal
with choices we have options and we
realize certain options and leave others
and touched
we also hierarch eyes we hierarch eyes
between
one two in three dimensions but we hire
our guys in size and I'll show you some
examples of that in a moment we also are
able to distinguish parts from a hole
and in different ways that is what I
have here called part on amis basically
one of the things that we see in this
whole story is that initially people or
whatever you call them go for these very
large stones that are the cores and they
take things off to create the shape they
want but at the time around 50,000 they
inverse that process and what they're
doing is they use the flakes that they
take off and they throw away the core so
that difference is also one that we can
demonstrate and then finally we begin to
see more and more complex ways in which
the stages of production are actually
intertwined because when you make
something each step also has
consequences for later ones and
sometimes in order to get the product
you have to reason back from the later
ones to the earlier ones and that begins
to be possible another thing that we can
do by that point is reduced dimensions
we can picture make pictures paintings
of three-dimensional objects and
actually depict them in a realistic way
in two dimensions now how did all these
people for this whole Pleistocene
essentially survive on the one hand by
not investing in the environment by only
harvesting what comes out of the
environment by following a multi
resource strategy and if things didn't
work out in one place anymore simply
moving somewhere else so adapting to
change in a spatial way and I'll get
back to that later on because one of our
problems is that we can't do that
anymore
and also by systematically staying below
the environments carrying capacity one
of the interesting data that we have
from Australia is that the only place in
Australia where people systematically
have famines in prehistory is in the
lush forests of the Marais and darling
rivers because their people were lured
into the idea that they could actually
have more and more people and
and they get tapped on by famines in the
very sparse areas of Australia you never
have any famine any trace of famine we
find famines in the bones and that is
why I can talk about that the other
thing is that people did not know how to
interact with the environment they only
reacted to it so the environment was
essentially left alone change and risk
were imminent all the time every minute
of the day but because they were there
was no cumulation of risks and I'll get
back to that later on people did to some
extent choose locations where they
minimize change for example and this is
something that applies to this region
where you're living but we find in
Greece that prehistoric people at the
end of the Paleolithic choose the
tectonic lee very active areas and why
do they choose them because those are
the areas where nature itself puts
itself regular regularly back to stage
zero where there is no long term change
because that is interrupted all the time
by the tectonics these are some of the
tools that come out of that phase and
when you compare with earlier images you
can see they become much smaller they
become composite like at the top right
hand image they be you get with the
Neolithic complete control over shape by
first taking off large flakes smaller
and smaller and smaller and then finally
grinding it so that you take out
individual grains and that gets you
complete control over shape and at the
same time what you begin to get is
things like basketry and I have given
here the examples of a fish trap and
some reconstructed basketry what is
interesting there is that we start from
the small we start from the single fiber
or the single twig and we first make
them into long one dimensional things
and then we make them into
two-dimensional things by weaving them
or in another way combining them so
those scales are things that are
normally operated around ten thousand
and that control over shape then is
complete but we also see interesting
things like for example that fish trap
but also pottery that gets introduced at
that time we see for the first time a
completely different topology we see a
topology of a solid around a void that
up to that moment all the objects are
solids but they never a solid that has a
shape around the void that means that by
that point we have a tangled hierarchy
of concepts surface that defines a
volume and that is defined by yet
another volume so we begin to stretch
that mentally as it were we also begin
to invert the sequence of manufacturing
one of the real problems with stone
tools is once you make a wrong blow you
have blown it and you have to start over
again you can't correct by the time you
begin to create your two and
three-dimensional objects from the
little pieces to the big pieces you can
actually correct and so you have a much
better chance of coming to an end result
and that happens with clay but that
happens with basketry that happens with
weaving and at the same time and pottery
is there a very good example you
actually stretch temporal sequences I
need to hurry a little bit because we're
going a little bit slow now let's look
at the next phase that is these last
10,000 years we all think about climates
but we very often don't realize that
that period is an incredibly stable
period compared to the earlier periods
that we have talked about and that leads
then also if you combine it with the
changes that are happening there - an
interesting question is climate the
driver or is climate the enabler what we
see with the Neolithic is people start
settling down they start doing
agriculture they start raising animals
they have all these new technologies
they begin to live in villages they
begin to live in larger groups and they
get a different perception of space and
time
one of the interesting things out of the
Australian data and in particular the
story about the song lines is that their
time and space are actually intertwined
in a very interesting way every
individual learns certain songs but
those songs only get a sense when that
person goes through the space that they
describe and so there is a feedback
between the spatial and the temporal
there is not a two dimensional map in
their head it's a one-dimensional map
and it's a one-dimensional map that is
hung on to time which is very different
from what we do later on if you look at
a book like Hugh Brody's on how in areas
where there is no maps people actually
define their territories it is very much
a 2-dimensional sort of pattern a
crucial difference here is that people
go from harvesting the environment to
investing in the environment people
start taking out forests burning down
the stuff that remains after they've cut
down the trees planting harvesting all
of that is a longer timeframe so time is
something that is beginning to get
conquered now mobility at that point
drops out at least to some extent as the
way to meet challenges and the question
that we've always been told is well that
is because of the Neolithic there was
some sort of progress idea that that
meant that we could finally do those
sorts of things my sense of it is that
that mobility mobiles mobile system
could have continued until the present
day and that it would have been
fantastic in the Neolithic because it
would have been a lot easier in some
ways so the question then is what drives
that change from the Pleistocene to the
Neolithic and my sense of it is that
that is the conceptual the cognitive
rather than anything else these are some
of the images that go with this you see
the villages you see Stonehenge you see
the Neolithic plowing we have the traces
of the plowing and we have the ploughs
as well we suddenly also begin to see
three
mention Allart objects which is a very
different story from what we had before
these are some other images of villages
particularly to show you that they can
be very very different depending on the
climate if you compare a skara brae in
the Orkneys with chital who you can
turkey you can see how different that is
but what did it do it changed the
dynamic with the environment and
climates it is now no longer only people
responding or harvesting things that are
done in the environment people actually
impact on the environment and we will
see it a little while that there are
instances where we can actually see that
impact we intervene more and more in
nature we try and control our
environmental risks by simplifying our
environment for example by extra gating
from the wild an area in which we do
agriculture over which we actually have
control we diversify spatially and
technically and as the system of course
integrates it also becomes more
vulnerable to all kinds of disturbances
so the emphasis shifts to problem
solving and that is part of that
feedback loop that I outlined earlier on
and as part of that we see people
diversifying in particular challenges
particular problems and we see larger
and larger interactive groups it's the
beginnings of people really dedicating
the time it needs to deal with specific
issues the cost of it of course is
growing social complexity and that means
more conflict and you have to find ways
to begin to deal with that conflict and
now we come to the next step which is
for me what I would call the sort of the
second revolution which is the origins
of cities and sewer then I talked about
this little bit beforehand I'm going to
try and argue that urbanization is not
as it has been seen for a long time a
way to be more efficient at least not in
energy terms once you get over a certain
threshold of size of the population it
means that you have to get your food so
far away you
footprint becomes so large that it
becomes actually from an energy
perspective very unequal amakura do that
so my point here is that it is again the
need to make a more efficient way of
dealing with the information processing
that brings people together by bringing
them closer together communication is
made a lot more efficient people get
more direct contact more intense contact
and that means that ultimately there is
a possibility to innovate more
effectively in the city than there is
outside and what is happening at that
point to my mind at least is that you
get a sort of flow structure in which
from the city organization goes outward
new ideas or innovations go outward and
once they are out where they facilitate
the bringing inside into the city the
energy that is necessary to feed all the
people that are there but for those
kinds of structures dynamic structures
to survive basically means that
innovation becomes a permanently
necessary thing because otherwise people
at the periphery after a little while
are no longer interested in
participating in this whole game the
other side of that is that of course by
bringing an invention in a city where
there are people with very many
different perspectives we also see that
that invention suddenly gets enriched by
being in a much lighter larger cognitive
sphere and therefore the possibility
that idle actually take off is enhanced
one of the interesting things about
cities is that they emerge in clusters
and I've given you here some examples
whether it's a Korea or the Maya and
other things that happen at the same
time but that are important to
understand this are the capability of
counting the capability of writing what
you have on the left hand side at the
top are tokens tokens that according to
a colleague Dinesh not Bharat are the
antecedents of actually the
first tablets in the first writing
because they signify an animal or an
object and they are given to somebody
who transports that object as a sign
that that is what it is so there are
also counters in a sense ultimately that
leads to making impressions from those
objects in the tablets in the Maya area
it's done differently in the Peruvian
area on the right-hand lo below it's
done differently yet again but what we
see in every case is there is a need to
have a material means to carry across
time and space certain symbols that say
something about what is going on in this
society at the same time once we get
people together we need to solve
conflicts we need to adieu
administration and what we see on the
left hand side is the famous column of
the laws of Hammurabi at the top we see
a clay tablet in cuneiform that is here
symbolizes the fact that you get a
bureaucracy and below that the Egyptian
scribe does the same thing and on the
right hand side you see an actual
archive that was excavated in Syria
about 30 years ago so those are aspects
that occur at the same time and that to
me to my mind are very much part of that
transition they would not have been
there if you hadn't had people in the
cities together the next revolution is
that this same thing happens on a much
larger scale and that is what I've
called here the Imperial evolution when
cities get up and running and attract
more and more people more and more
energy is needed so that has to come
from further and further away and
ultimately that comes from so far away
that it comes across cultural boundaries
across linguistic boundaries and that is
only possible for a particular reason
that I will mention in a moment when
there is in those areas to which the
power of the city expands treasure that
can be taken in
and that can actually pay for the act of
extending the empire one of the
beautiful arguments launched by a
colleague here in the United States that
I appreciate a lot Joseph Tainter is
that the Roman Empire was only able sort
of to spread on the back of an earlier
phase in which organization had spread
and treasure was accumulated and that as
soon as the Romans could no longer find
new treasure the Empire actually started
getting into trouble part of that
process is of course that power to do
things becomes power over control
becomes important institutions formal
institutions and their roles from
conflict resolution we get to the stage
of resource and people management roads
and communication become important and
that is what this slide is all about the
first the left-hand side shows the
expansion of the Roman Empire through
time and the right-hand side shows the
huge network of roads that are another
component of this need to communicate
more efficiently and to exchange more
information that spread over the Empire
now the first moment that we have
actually anthropogenic climate change is
in that Roman period and it's not on a
global scale this graph shows a whole
series of ways of registering climate
change that relate either to the polar
ice caps or to the atmosphere that are
truly global the only one at the bottom
the black one is a regional one and it
is based on erosion of soil and there we
see suddenly a peak in the second
century AD that doesn't appear on a
global scale and so we actually argue
that that is the result of human
intervention because the Romans at that
point Institute what I can only call a
sort of proto agra agra industry all
over the empire to feed people in Rome
this is the collapse as soon as there is
no longer tray
to be had the Romans get to the edge of
the Empire the Rhine the Danube the
desert in the south and it's very
interesting to hear Caesar complain when
he gets to Belgium I am a very good
soldier I do a lot of fighting but I'm
useless here because there are no things
that I can conquer there are no armies
that I can conquer there are no cities
that I can destroy there is non
organization and so I cannot do anything
here anymore what you see at the same
time on the right hand side here
is that once that stage has been reached
that there is no new treasure to be
found you see by the devaluation of the
the basement of the Roman coins how
actually the inflation must go very very
quickly very high up and ultimately by
the end of the Empire we find that local
entities detach themselves from the
Empire and how do we find that we have a
fantastic source in the South of France
you may have seen the pont du gard
which is this fantastic Roman aqueduct
well if you look inside it and you
analyse the carbon or the calcium
carbonate that is deposed by the water
on the edges you can do that sort of by
periods of 20-30 years and you see that
from the 3rd century onward the water
becomes actually very dirty you see that
people start tapping it out of the
aqueduct for their own latif india so
that the city no longer controls even
its own hinterland that to my mind is
how things go until around 1800 by 1800
with the Industrial Revolution we've
actually temporarily solved the energy
constraint we begin to use fossil energy
and when we do that innovation explodes
and very quickly we our societies become
dependent on innovation and that is
where we are now innovation becomes
endemic you could say because that is a
word that has recently been used a lot
in the financial crisis that innovation
is the biggest Ponzi
because you have to keep going and going
and going and going faster otherwise it
won't work and that is where we are at
this particular point and on the right
hand at the left hand side here you see
actually how the energy needs and the
energy use hugely expands we use in our
society about a 10,000 watts per person
a human being needs a hundred watts the
other 99 times a hundred watts actually
go in maintaining our society and our
material culture okay what is the
underlying pattern and I have to go fast
on this but I just want to basically say
that once the biological constraints of
innovation have been overcome we see
innovations leading to challenges
leading to innovations humans overcome
every major hurdle every time but they
do so by very fundamentally changing
their society and how they are actually
organized how is that dynamic driven and
to my mind it is driven between by a
tangled hierarchy between two
perceptions of the relationship between
society and environment and I'm getting
to that in the next slide based on the
work of people like Kahneman and the
Stanford School we know that there is a
relationship between the direction of a
comparison whether it starts with a
subject towards a reference or the other
way around
that determines whether we stress in a
comparison in a categorization
similarity or dissimilarity as a result
we find and we have documents in
ethnography that certain categories can
be open that is we know what may be part
of them but we don't know yet what won't
be part of them whereas at a later stage
when that comparison has also turned in
the other direction we actually close
the category and then we know what is in
it and what is not in it apply that to
the environment and think about it and I
have taken these two phrase
sure it's meteor and Alvin Moe because
they're both still actively used in the
language in the case of meteor humanity
is compared to nature the cohesion of
nature it's unknown aspects and its
strangeness and force are amplified the
confusion and the handicaps of humanity
are accentuated humanity is passive in a
natural environment that is active and
aggressive change is attributed to
nature and people have no other choice
but to adapt to that so natural changes
tend to be viewed as dangerous because
they're beyond the control of humanity
now look at the other perspective that
inverts the to the society and the
environment and their nature is compared
to humanity the cohesion and the
strength of nature are diminished and
it's known aspects are emphasized the
cohesion and strengths are accentuated
in humanity humanity is active and
aggressive in a natural environment that
is passive humanity tends to be viewed
as the source of all change people as
creating their environment and over the
last 50 years we've actually gone to
both those stages but right now we're at
a point where we are beginning to look
at their interaction and the interesting
thing to my mind is that these two
opposite perspectives reinforce each
other in one particular way that natural
dangers are exaggerated and those of
human intervention are systematically
underplayed and undervalued so that we
intervene more and more in our natural
environment because we think that we
thereby reduce our risks but what we
don't know and we don't realize is that
we're also only changing the spectrum of
risks we're not in any way reducing the
risks so ultimately society loses
control because the more it transforms
its surroundings the less it understands
them that leads and this is a known fact
for example that we have studied links
all across the Mediterranean that
complex ecological systems come
Syst of hierarchies of dynamics on all
kinds of scales that the faster dynamics
take control over the slower ones and
usually these faster ones are the human
ones but ultimately there is a role
reversal between the two the human
dynamics that are rapid but initially
didn't have much impact because nature
dominated very much begin to control the
slower natural dynamics that are more
encompassing so what happens is that
ultimately and this is Israeli
colleagues have studied this in great
depth that landscapes become what we
call disturbance dependent they become
dependent on humans to actually be
maintained as they are and finally
talking back on that risk spectrum any
society's risk spectrum shifts over time
with respect to its environments because
what we do is we overemphasize the
frequent risks that we see regularly we
do something about them we reduce them
we take out those frequent risks and we
substitute by our actions into the
environment completely new completely
unknown risks of much larger at least
some of them of much larger
temporalities and so ultimately what i
think you see is that you get a risk
barrier by analogy to a sound barrier
you get a buildup of risks that
ultimately creates a collapse okay I
think I would then summarize at some
point any social environmental system
will go out of control because those
dynamics that I've just outlined are
irreversible what points in that
direction the appropriation of nature
the human perception of the relationship
between people in the environment the
risk perception and the relation between
cognition and action which I have not
really gone into here with I can do that
in the discussion if you want the
effects are that the system pushes
itself into a trap that short-term
solutions create long-term problems that
the cost of problem solving goes up
flexibility goes down we get a number of
those time bombs and then the real
question is
the outcome at the end of for example
the Roman Empire and how far is the way
it ended already included in the way it
was started that is in how our
perception of our environment has
exploited that environment and by
exploiting it has created the weaknesses
that we get confronted with at the end
and now that this is really the last
slide this is then we are now at a
completely new stage for the first time
we are beginning to get control over
information itself we have control over
energy we have control over matter
we are facing an incredible
transformation in the next 50 years in
nanotechnology biotechnology and
what-have-you
in order to shape our future we must
first of all and this is I think the
main thrust of my argument here
understand the process of innovation
itself what we don't know is how we
relate our perspective on the past our
lessons from the past to the future in a
scientific and coherent way and that is
something we can discuss later in the
discussion a bit more in detail I have
some ideas about it but it has to do
with the fact that because we have this
limited short time working memory we
basically cannot handle the total
complexity of the phenomena whether
their past or future for the past we get
out of that by creating a narrative that
tells us how the past was and that can
be changed as archaeologists do at every
occasion if we look towards the future
we don't do that we set out a path and
then simply say well it has such an such
a probability we need to get into that
dynamic if we're going to be able to
solve some of these things and I do
believe that modern information
technology can actually help us with
that in some ways and then in the end of
course if we manage this we will
actually have to adapt our social
structures our institutions to this much
better use of innovation because in the
end it is the rampant innovation of the
last two centuries
that has led us to the crisis where we
currently are thank you very much yeah
thank you however you want Thank You
Sandra I had a couple of questions as we
were doing along the way and then I'll
catch up with some of the questions
coming for the audience one was you've
had a picture of Jericho
yeah great Neolithic town 10,000 years
plus old I guess in some sense
continuously occupied to that area has
been ever since in the middle of the
Jarek hotel
there's the stub of a tower yeah the
stub is 30 feet high the diameter of
that stub is 30 feet across what the
hell were those people up to I don't
know this is one of the limits of
archaeology can carry a doctor's sight
it was in a phase in which military
interpretations were very important part
of the interpretations of what urbanism
was all about so she actually fell for
that tower and that is why Jericho has
the name of being a town if you compare
its size wise with a number of these
other settlements it's actually very
small it could also be a village and we
don't know we honestly don't know within
there it's associate of the wall or they
walling something in or walling
something I think they probably were I
think in every situation you get defense
there's no question about that whether
it's a village whether it's a town but I
don't believe that defense itself is
enough of an argument to actually build
a town or to start sort of living in a
particular way I know that this is very
cogent and very often used argument in
archaeology but I don't believe it and I
give you a wonderful example the mobile
play in France they had this huge hill
and they began digging and they dug this
fantastic gate and 20 yards beyond the
gate the wall stops the gate is entirely
symbolic
and so it's the wool it is to impress
people as they come in on the road I'm
just saying that because I think we have
to be extremely careful I'm very much a
skeptic
Oh building a wall and they just ran out
of funds that happens a lot I don't
believe that what they have done instead
actually build an earthen bank all
around so I don't think it's but to give
you a sense I'm really a skeptic on
those kinds of interpretations because
they're ad-hoc particular
interpretations in particular instances
and what we have to deal with here and
why I have made the argument as I have
is because we are dealing with a
universal phenomenon and it has
variables how it happens in one place or
happens in another place but the process
itself to my mind that drives it is
still this one another thing that the
developed in the process is we're
getting toward bigger cities and
collaborations of cities which itself is
interesting and then on toward Empire at
a certain point you have sort of civil
servants there's some kind of
bureaucracy in the accounting of stuff
in archives yes what the hell is the use
of an archive it is either the priestly
caste or the powers-that-be
the document every trade transaction
with a distant area we have thousands of
tablets in those archives why would they
keep that more than a year or two it's a
very that is one way to become an empire
then yeah but another thing you could
basically say is that their perception
of time is a very different one and that
we are in a short-term thinking society
and that a number of those societies
actually I think were thinking much more
long-term than we are and that's why you
need to ask the question why do we throw
it away
rather than ask them why they keep it
yeah so the societies had stories
themselves you know sort of quasi
history and songs and song lines in the
rest of it what was in the archives was
that part of this kind of longitudinal
self-identification of the society
mainly accounting from mediation in
conflicts adjudication of conflicts
those kinds of things to the point so
there's a case law building up in some
ways you could say that oh okay
alexandros just handed me a question by
the Alexandrian says this seems to argue
that our stable environment has made us
less able to adapt the climate
environment yeah
will the coming changes in climate
increase our W STW am a short term
that's an interesting question as a
culture right there is those climate
change good or bad for us in terms of
innovation in terms of innovation let me
answer it this way I think it is the
fact that there was a continual demand
for change which during the Pleistocene
apart from the biological factors but
I'm not talking to at the end of the
Pleistocene when s CWM was no longer the
actual limiting factor has kept people
on their toes permanently changing and I
think the big difference where we are
now faced with is that we have invested
so much that we can't change so easily
anymore and so that we can only innovate
within the structure that we have
created for ourselves and that way we
actually go from one technology to the
next and we aggravate in the longer term
the situation without being able to say
okay let's break let's do something else
and so I would argue that now to answer
your final question is climate change
good or bad for us I don't think it's
bad for Humanity I think it's bad for
our societies and our social structures
I think we will survive I think we will
find solutions for these problems
there's gonna be a huge amount of
collateral damage was the fall of the
Roman Empire or solution no it is it's
not a solution it's not a problem
what happened these people moved away
from the cities when rural and survived
that way that's part of what interests
me about that is Rome fell all the
cities in Europe fell no what happened
is that after the sixth century the
backbone of the highly evolved urban
system went I don't know how many energy
levels down and how many demographic
levels down but it actually remained in
function it was taken over by the church
much lower population a much lower
population like a tenth or even less
what happened though is that the whole
rural situation completely collapsed
right what we see culture went down
along with their everything and a lot of
know-how was lost so ceramic know-how
glass know-how a whole bunch of know-how
was lost and what we see then is that
from the 10th century that builds itself
up again but in different ways right
what we see is that the rural settlement
pattern from the 10th century has
nothing to do with the earlier the Roman
one because people think differently
about their landscape right this is
pretty scary because you're you know the
the the city is the total keeper of
everything at this point you lose the
city use everything that it was giving
how does this relate to your current
risk certainty of the recent research in
Europe between city and town there the
city in in rural areas what we were sent
out by the European Union
and the interesting thing about this is
as much political as anything else to
begin to investigate why there were so
many problems in agricultural policy in
southern Europe and this was done first
under the guise of desertification and
we got rid of that we actually
anecdotally very interestingly it turns
out that the english-speaking people and
the french-speaking people understand
such completely different things by that
that you can't make it into any kind of
reasonable argument
but what happened then is we moved over
the 10 years from desertification to the
concept of land degradation so it became
a perceptual category and ultimately we
realized that what came out as rural
problems were essentially urban problems
that were due to an F different
perception of what life was all about
that began to attract people in the
rural areas and that shifted their
decision-making from remaining on the
land and practicing there to wanting to
do something else so the villages in
that part of Europe are emptying out
like everywhere else in the world what
happens next in that sequence what
happens next in that sequence and this
is a very good exercise for me I have to
say because I'm too much of an
archaeologist and not enough of a
futurologist I think ultimately what
we'll find is that the city system will
explode because one of the clear things
about the current situation is that on
the one hand we focus more and more on
the urban but on the other hand urban is
actually the most vulnerable part of our
system because it brings the most people
together it was wonderful after Katrina
the CEO of Munich reinsurance came on
television in this country and said you
know the only way to avoid this is not
build any cities anymore
because then we don't have any risks
this is a very interesting lesson we
live and we focus because innovation has
now become so important on our urban
systems but in the same way you can
actually see that those urban systems
have the most difficult energy problems
and have the energy constrained there is
major and I one point did an exercise
which never got published wisely about
how Phoenix would fall to pieces because
that's where I live now and so we
started thinking about all the things
that would be going wrong
I would guess one of the first things
that's going wrong is that now and it's
actually happening right now there are
so many people that have left that we
can't maintain the infrastructure
anymore the famous infrastructure
problem yes
a good question from Ken Wilson says we
seem to be stuck at the 7 plus or minus
2 which goes back to Miller or who was
that back when Oh among others yes but
there's a whole bunch of people there
maybe this is not quite enough for us as
a society dynamics than a Trappist can
we I mean it stood as some good stead
for the lo these many tens of thousands
years is it time to move beyond plus or
minus 2 I think that is what our
information technology has to do I think
we need something very fundamentally
believe that we need to start building
models of how this process of reduction
of dimensions actually goes what the
weaknesses and the bias is in it are and
see if we can on the basis of that kind
of work begin to find models that help
us sink in more dimensions and therefore
basically add to our capability not
biologically but technically extra
working memory for people working
together say good little worker you know
capable of managing more than seven plus
or minus two and does that scale up to
some extent but there is of course a
Loss Factor a major loss factor and that
expresses itself in the way actually
particularly in hierarchical situations
how you begin to get on the one hand
more efficiency but less adaptability
because hierarchical situations focus
themselves much more in relatively fixed
patterns as they lose their leaves as
routines take over where as a market
system a distributed system actually has
much less of that but that has the
problem that it can be much larger but
at the same time it has inefficiency so
you begin to get all kinds of exchanges
between those two kinds of structures
that battle it out essentially among
others in urban systems so the urban
systems and you're talking about the
information processing basically we're
talking about story of information
processing along comes the Internet
and it seems to be in your scheme kind
of like what happened in 1800 we
suddenly mastered energy in a certain
way we now I think you're saying
mastering is permeating - yes beginning
to master information in a certain way
the city experiments so far is kind of
the one level of mastering information
and in a compressed time-space mode the
internet seems to offer mastering
information in a way that is not so
compressed that space for sure and maybe
not in time that's right is this the
bigger better city is it replacing the
city what is it what it will ultimately
do I don't know but I do believe there
is the possibility in there so at least
lessen the stresses that our current
focus on urban systems is actually
creating because we can spread out more
evenly but we don't know people you know
get exactly push connected by the cell
phone to town and then they follow this
but so we have not made the mental
switches that would actually enable that
to be materialized but the rewards are
doing that I think we could get him
there but I don't think we have done it
yet a question from melmac McKay
Mackie okay many sociobiology
socio biologists cite the development of
complex verbal languages the key to
human development where do you believe
language and the ability to share
learning with large groups fits into all
this I think it is a major part of it
it's only the part that as an
archaeologist I have a really really
hard time demonstrating until the
writing comes up but it's clear that I
think if you think now just sort of
polarizing between small groups of let's
say 25 to 50 people which is what
hunter-gatherers are all about they
communicate by very many different
signals body language eyes all kinds of
emotional signals as soon as you get
larger groups there is no longer the
time for that people start having more
intermittent contacts so one of the
things that must happen is that language
becomes more
and concepts become clearer and it
becomes easier to understand exactly
what is meant you lose a lot of new ends
and so I would argue that one of the
functions of writing is not so much to
communicate what you want but they could
not communicate what you don't want
because you don't give all these other
signals anymore you actually only put in
writing that would you exactly want to
say and I think that's an other function
of writing that is happening at that
moment so this is why so many of us
prefer to relate by email rather than in
person or by phone you can pair it right
down to what you can control
what's the head the future of that I
wonder question I booked Orion for this
whole earth discipline book and oddly
enough the constant question I get and
I'll bet you get it too is well gosh
professor are you optimistic or
pessimistic based on your frame of every
time I have a long debate right now in
Italy about that one of the great
privileges of an anthropologist or
archeologists is that you look at it
with such a distance that it is not your
own Society and so for the human species
I am actually optimistic I think we will
find ultimately a kind of solution at
the same time I think if I look at it
from the perspective of my own society
that society will have to either fall by
the wayside or be transformed in such a
way that's unrecognizable and that is
what I meant earlier on when I said
there's going to be a lot of collateral
damage climate change or just the sheer
self acceleration of innovation forces
this absolutely both I think the the
acceleration of innovation is a huge
danger in the sense that it's also what
helps us but it's an interesting danger
socially we are going to get with the
nanotechnology the biotechnology a
narrower and narrower part of the
population that actually knows what
these technologies
about and because of that we're going to
get quite some interesting social
problems it's not my experience with
biotechnology where young biotechnology
hackers basically but what about all
these other people out there that's what
I'm talking about I think there's going
to be a disconnect groups that control
this and the groups that don't okay
remember the digital divide yes we go to
conferences and people would fret and
the last day were beginning all worked
up about the digital divide those four
four people I'll never catch up with
those people with our Apple computers
and they got cell phones and they swept
right on packages absolutely right and
that may happen again and I wouldn't put
it past them in a different way but I do
believe that what is very important in
these kind of innovations is that each
of them opens up for a particular window
of time and if we miss that window of
time then we're in trouble if we
actually work it within that window of
time we're fine then we can do the
reorganization that is actually needed
I'm taking as an example the European
Union where it is political but there's
two elements there it's the agriculture
interestingly enough the agriculture
policy was designed for northern Europe
for the continuous plains so you could
devise a policy for a policy for
averages in southern Europe the
landscape is such that you have much
more aberration than average look
mathematically speaking but in the sense
of landscape and so one of the real
stresses in snow when the harvest will
be really bad and another really good
your regional much more up and down all
kinds of regional differences that mean
that those kinds of subsidized policies
really don't work in this house what
you're getting there is that and we see
that very very strongly the last 15
years since 92 is this dis effect a ssin
with the policies that have been put in
place with the way the whole system
works that is I think one of the biggest
reasons why there is such a huge
slowdown in creating the European Union
and I see similar things that you could
happen look at how a GM's
genetically modified organisms are being
dealt with in Europe major major
problems at the level of the society
uh-huh very very difficult to overcome
one of the real fears is that
nanotechnology will come up against the
same sort of problems we're actually
having a Center at ASU that's beginning
to study that I'm not so sure that
society can follow what you're saying if
you want becomes a sort of innovation
back order that's kind of a healthy way
to go under the circumstances
interesting I don't think it's
necessarily a healthy way to go I don't
think there is in that sense that much
of a sort of a value to be attached to
it what I'm basically arguing is it may
be one of the solutions but it'll have
other kinds of consequences whereas if
you have it as it goes here in the
United States you will have different
consequence so the system is being
driven apart that's basically what I'm
saying
well variability is supposedly good for
evolution because then you see which
works and doesn't let me reason quit
there's Phelim Jeffery West who just
retired as president of Santa Fe
Institute who's worked with the Songer
and Jeff is the one who came up with
this amazing realization that cities
basically create problems and then
innovate faster than the problems that
create that's one of the reasons are the
engines of innovation that sunders been
talking about and that's a good news you
know cities a force innovation they
teach innovation to the world to the
regions around the rural areas and then
to each other in the world and through
the internet the best practices swarm
around very rapidly and this is all very
happy story but and and Jeffrey says
look this has nothing to do with
ideologies or theory is there in the
data people in big cities work faster
think faster act faster move faster
adapt faster innovate faster than in
small cities and there's a nice scale
it's even superlinear the bigger they
are the super faster they go so far this
is a happy story all based on data
and then Jeffrey West says you keep
getting new sets of innovations which
take off and they're coming more and
more rapidly and pretty soon he's
talking recruits while singularity at
which point his face Falls and he says
this is terrible this is a self-limiting
phenomenon this is a situation which we
crash into something and a bad thing
then happens now my view is that he
doesn't have any data at this his
worries do you share his worry and and
what do you do with that worry if you
have it because it seems to be a form of
what you've just been described as
innovating ourselves into unsolvable
situations what what I'm basically
saying is the more we and every
innovation creates a cascade of no
challenges right the more innovations
you do and the faster you do them the
less time you actually have to begin to
deal with that cascade and so ultimately
it's different what is happening that is
different very much so and so you learn
from mistakes the mistakes add up and
they take you down yeah that's what I
said about the shifting in the risk
spectrum by shifting towards the longer
end and the unknown end and I think that
is one of the drivers why over a long
culture like the Romans you actually go
from a long term perspective is to a
shorter perspective because you get so
many dimensions in which there are
immediate problems that you start
focusing on those and you no longer can
take the longer-term ones actually into
account so under these under that view
Europe is a much safer place to be than
say China China China's addicted to
innovation and as jamming China has huge
problems I was in China a couple of
years ago at the request of the Chinese
government as part of this
organization on the human dimensions of
climate of climate and environmental
change and they gave us a special
seminar about some of those problems the
fact that you have 300 million people
that is the whole population to us
seasonally mobile between cities and
countryside's the fact that you have
cities where industry is decrepit like
the old steel built in the US where
there is a million immigrants a year
China is totally addicted and China is
going to run into a huge problem at some
point and they know it that is why they
keep their money low because they need
eight or ten percent increase in in
gross national product a year to
actually be able to keep that more or
less focused are the is there any other
culture that is aware of the problem
that way because the US has the same
problem we don't seem to be aware of it
that well what I admire about the
Chinese is they have much longer-term
thinking if you see how they've dealt
with Hong Kong for example how they're
dealing with Taiwan without immediately
pulling out the guns and basically
saying okay it'll take a century but
it'll happen anyway I think that's
basically what is happening I think they
have a particular way of thinking about
time which is very very different from
ours and it may end up that they will do
the same thing as we're doing and
they'll end up ultimately having to deal
with so many problems that it becomes
much more short-term thinking I'm not
precluding that but at the stage where
they are right now I admire them for
their long long term thinking complete
shift of question you've spent a lot of
time with archaeology including some in
the field and you've watched the process
of archeology the the tools the range of
stuff that's going on in the various
cultures that are doing their own
archaeology now and on and on the long
now foundation is attempting some
archaeology of the future and it raises
the question of we we asked
archaeologists like you what if we were
creating archeology to bind future
generations to the way that past
archeology helps bind us to to them to
those past generation what is the right
way to do sort of the plant archeology
now there is no right way okay because
essentially what happened is that in
five hundred years they will want a
narrative that is suited to their period
and their time archaeologist to my mind
our prophets turned backwards that's
fair so are we you're saying that we
should give them lots of options to
misunderstand what we're doing that's
right I want to take one other example
here which is something that has struck
me which occurred to me a long long time
ago I had a PhD student in Cambridge
from Papua New Guinea from the Highlands
and we had a debate about time on the
one hand and about warfare on the other
but the time element is that I want to
highlight here he basically says you
Westerners I really don't understand you
you think that you stand with your face
towards the future you don't know the
future so you're standing with your back
towards it
all you're trying to do is you're trying
to keep some sort of a course going
there that you actually calibrate on
what you see in front of you which is
the past so it's dead reckoning not
navigation yeah and is he claiming that
they do something different no that's
that's what his perspective is he says
we don't do that their perspective is
you stand with your back towards the
future hmm and you actually do it that
way and that's a safer way to behave no
yeah if you're a wonderful example of
how it went wrong there's a tribe in the
southern highlands called the Huli who
like most of those tribes actually lives
on the ridge and they at one point saw
the environment changing and from that
perspective to redress the fact that
they were getting off course as it were
going towards the future what did they
see changing then something in the end
deforestation deforestation and
particular but I'll get to that in a
moment
so they go back to the past to see where
things may have gone wrong that demands
a ceremony the ceremony demands that you
raise a lot of pigs and that you
slaughter those pigs oops so ultimately
you have more and more pigs the
environment gets completely ruined by
the pigs and ultimately the tribe ends
up in the valley in the marsh that they
have created themselves they ran out of
pigs it's similar thing happen at Easter
Island when they're doing bigger and
bigger statues until they ran out of
trees to roll them on and then the
statutes were to prevent the climate
change or the landscape change that they
yeah so we don't do ceremonies and I
guess we don't use scarce materials but
what would you like to find in the you
know dig down underneath that stub and
Jericho what the tower
what would you just love to find under
there I mean it's a tell so there's
layers and layers of layers right
absolutely absolutely I don't think that
I would go for what a lot of the
archaeologists would go for let's try
and find the oldest site or the origins
what I would love to do is do the it
reverse and dismantle to tell to such a
point that I can actually begin to look
at how it built itself up so reverse
time and actually use a generative
perspective on that tell rather than a
perspective looking at the origins of
something look it creates an ex ante
perspective on what is going on in the
tale rather than do what most
archaeologists who is actually look at
it from an expose perspective
I mean dig incense dig from the bottom
rather than from the top actually the
excavations are done in in Syria we try
to get around that problem by not
digging like this but by digging like
this deep traction no no only but
digging the hotel away the hole
vertically Wow
rather than horizontal all the way down
to
pre-human yeah and then through the
hotel so that every time you actually
can see where a lair and a period ends
when you do it from the top you only see
that's the beginning of something when
you've gone through it right and then
you get into the problem of destroying
it because you don't understand
so you did that what did you learn that
was different it is very different you
can actually come up with a much more
coherent perspective on the dynamics
that is going on in a particular tool
now of course tell is a very small scale
so you that will not tell me something
about how a culture has changed it will
only tell me how that village has
changed but we had a lot more detail out
of that than you would have in the other
way this suggest a plan going forward
that I think climate change could help
the sea levels are gonna rise anyway if
New Orleans instead of shipping its
trash out of town he had kept it there
and made itself a tell no rising on its
own debris yeah that's what they didn't
hold on for years
really of course well there you are and
then every once in a while a high sea
house would slide down and then mount
right and you would have images where
people put a rope around it and pulled
it back up literally I'm not kidding you
I can see that the future is as we have
all suspected Dutch thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you